He could also fight at 85 I think Tyron has legitimate potential to be a three
division champions.
He should start Isas stuck on rally and for that,
for that 65 pound weight class,
nobody listens to me anymore.
If they listened to me,
Melvin Manhoef would've been in the UFC back in 2002 yeah,
they listen to me sometimes.
I think they listened to me with Ben Aspirin online on record,
and I'm gonna say I'm a big reason why Ben asked her and gotten the UFC.
I brokered a meeting between him and Dana White.
Okay,
dude.
I put it together.
I called Dana.
I said,
look,
he's a good guy,
man.
He's talking shit.
But everybody talks shit like,
come on.
I'm like the guys undefeated.
And he's like,
uh.
He was like,
when Andy wants to go to sleep,
it takes Ben ask him
and I'm like,
it's fighting.
See,
the thing about fighting is it's not a matter of what is like the,
what's exciting to watch for a person like you?
A person like me who's like sitting down,
how is this going to play out?
What's gonna work?
What works?
Yeah,
I get that.
Yeah.
I want to see what works.
When,
when I see a guy like Ben asked and I want to see what works.
Wow.
He's a three to one favorite over Robbie Lawler.
Holy Shit.
That's crazy.
They just had another fight to this card.
Listen man,
you can't sleep on Robbie fucking law.
Well,
don't sleep on Robbie Lawler.
That's crazy.
Three to one they didn't.
One is horrible.
Blue Robbie Lawler can wrestler.
Robbie Lawler has been shutting people's lights out since the fucking early two
thousands decent bet.
Then it's a fucking very good.
I would take,
I mean,
I would take the Robbie's all the,
it's,
it's actually three to one.
Yeah.
A hundred to make 300 if law,
it's t plus two 30 so you'd wait.
Oh,
oh,
he's a three to one.
So you'd have to win the bet three to win one on aspirin,
correct?
Yeah.
I'd take that bad.
It's a good bet.
But I'd like aspirins chances because I think that wrestling is just on another
level.
Yeah.
That's the fight.
Here's the fight,
one 65 Khabib,
Ben ass grin.
Whoo.
I guess bank,
it makes 6500% he can make 6500% a hundred percent he wants to make 65 cause
he's good friends with Tyron and he's like,
I'll be the 65 pound champ tire and be the 70 or 75 whatever they decide to go
with.
That's,
that's the fight man.
Could be.
Versus Ben Aspirin because I'm telling you man,
Ben Aspirin,
they just put his face on the,
on the camera the other day while he was in the crowd and the audience went
crazy.
He doesn't even fought in the UFC and they love him.
Yeah.
Fight real fight fans.
Know who that they know who he is now.
They know who he is now.
It's like he's been building momentum.
The hardcore fans.
Absolutely.
You're excited that finally this undefeated phenol phenom of a wrestler is
fighting in the UFC?
Yeah,
I would.
Yeah.
I would pay money to lodge him.
Fuck yeah,
for sure.
A lot of money.
I'll fly to Russia for that fight.
You think that's where they'd have it?
Fuck,
I don't know,
man.
I'm going to fly to Russia and commentate that fight.
Yeah.
And I'm going to,
as soon as I get to my hotel room,
I'm going to have one of them things.
It checks for bugs.
Did you check for hidden cameras and
you got to rush him back.
What's that up like a Christmas tree?
It'll probably would write the whole house is a fucking bug.
Yeah,
man.
I think that's,
uh,
that's,
that's a fight that I'm very,
very excited about.